okay
so
is
forces surround and eliminate my showmen
hey
oh
do
there's that outpost we detected the
armory of reckoning a munitions depot
well supplied and well defended be
careful
[Music]
we need to do some lasting damage to the
operation
looks like the unsc isn't the only one
worn down after six months of fighting
i'm only detecting three functioning
ammo printers
let's bring that count down to a nice
round zero
i think that got their attention
banished reinforcements inbound
is
[Applause]
um
[Music]
wow
okay that's a lot of guns
i think we've hit the mother lode take
your pick chief
[Applause]
have faced many challenges
and overcome them all
the yoke of the covenant
the resistance of humanity
our
restless
and now
are you worried that some amongst our
ranks believe themselves more deserving
of status
and
[Applause]
control your forces
[Applause]
[Music]
hit me
[Music]
[Applause]
but it's been rough on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe 20.
[Applause]
was keeping good marks at the nipple
academy
things
[Applause]